and welcome to sites I'm professor tom
Keaney I'm the associate director of
strategic studies here at Zeiss and it's
my pleasure to introduce and have a
conversation along with you with mr.
Edward Lucas talking about his book
cyber phobia you've I think it has a
great deal of interest and really in two
different ways for this audience and
others one is your own personal security
of your computer your information your
bank accounts and all sorts of other
things in the second of all that he also
deals with in the book is the national
security issues involved of all that you
can imagine they've read about that
cyber how cyber can affect nation's
defenses utilities security systems of
all kinds and I think we've already seen
many examples of that
mr. Lucas is a senior editor at The
Economist if you've seen on his bio he
says a long career as a correspondent in
both Russia and Eastern Europe I should
point out one book that I'm familiar
with published in 2008 called the new
Cold War in ER came out with a revision
in 2013 and 2013 2014 which if you take
a look at it you'll see that many of the
things that he said earlier or even more
true than true now that were predicted
back then now but tonight the subject is
cyber phobia and now we'll just have mr.
Lucas talk about his book then we will
engage you in the audience and questions
that you want to ask and we'll have a
much more general discussion we are good
here until at least six o'clock so with
that mr. Lucas well well thanks very
much indeed first of all for having me
here to all the people who've been
involved in organizing it I presented
the new Cold War at sites in 2008 and it
was a pretty skeptical audience then
that was a time when people still
thought that we were having some
temporary difficulties in our
relationship with Russia
and there's temporary difficulties seem
to become quite permanent and I actually
wish that I've been proved wrong no one
would have been happier than me if they
had been temporary difficulties we've
gone back to having a good relationship
with Russia and our allies in Eastern
Europe had stayed safe and unthreatened
and not invaded and I hope say that on
this I'll turn out to be too gloomy as
well because my message is quite a
gloomy one I think that we've designed
the Internet putting convenience and low
cost and innovation and flexibility as
the absolute priorities and we've been
doing that for twenty thirty years and
we've never really made security a
priority and the result is that we have
a huge amount of vulnerabilities baked
into the system we have insecure
software which people are still using
they have insecure hardware which people
are still using we have badly designed
networks we have vulnerabilities all
over the place which can be exploited by
any number of the possible categories of
malefactors we have spies hostile
governments hostile military operations
conducted over computers and networks we
have the hooligans and the activists and
pranksters and then we have the
criminals and although it makes sense to
divide them up into those categories
when were looking at them as threat
actors many of the tools they're using
are really similar
the wizard a vulnerability bit of social
engineering that could be used by anyone
and people did say to me when I first
started writing this ah why are you
turning your attention from European
security which you care a little bit
about even if many people think you're
wrong and mad to internet security which
you don't have a record on and actually
as I started researching this I became
more and more aware of the parallels
that we built up a European security
order at the end of the Cold War
basically with the Paris Charter onwards
that was based on an assumption of
goodwill and trust that we all basically
get on we may have our difficulties that
we can resolve them and this rules based
security order with very few sanctions
but lot of
cooperation dialogue will work for the
indefinite future and that's pretty much
the way we set the Internet's are
assuming at the beginning was going to
be for academic purposes we never
thought about questions of identity and
Alan MRC and then we never thought about
e-commerce it was actually against the
rules such as they were to use the
internet for commercial purposes back
back in the beginning and if anyone had
said back then this is going to become
the central nervous system model life
we're going to use it for all our vital
messaging for e-commerce for banking
from our critical infrastructure for all
these things a lot of those people in
the early days would said well hang on
it's not really designed for that are
you sure that you really want to go down
this road but we went down it because it
worked it was cheap it was convenient as
flexible you could develop it and so now
we're quite stuck and I think one of the
first messages of my book is this is
gonna get worse and quite possibly a lot
worse before it gets better
we've actually become habituated
accustomed to really serious breaches if
I'd said five ten years ago OPM is going
to be hacked and 20 million files on
government servants are going to be
stolen well first of all people have
said what's a p.m. 10 15 years ago they
might have said what's hacked but we
have these breaches happening all the
time nerves to the point that it's
actually quite difficult as a journalist
and I cover cyber security for the
Economist to get to the base to report
this my friends at the FT and other
papers go to the news editor on say mega
corpse just been found 10 million
customer details gone maybe the Chinese
may be criminals we don't know all sorts
of implications and the response of news
editor in most news organizations is
come a same-old same-old why is that
different from the breach we're out a
story about last week so we've got used
to the idea that breaches are normal but
actually they're not tens of billions of
dollars a year are flowing out of our
pockets into the criminal economy now
I'm very skeptical of the estimates that
are made by cyber security companies
because obviously they've gotten
interest in talking the threat up and
also who really knows but people are
talking about 500 billion dollars a year
and that's not just a loss to us a long
chunk of that is going into the pockets
of some of the worst people on the
planet people who would like to do us
harm in other ways so I'm quite clean me
about that what are we going to do about
it we can get onto that more in the Q &
A but the first thing I think is we have
to start speaking English or German or
Chinese or Russian or any other language
that people normal people actually speak
and the most important feature I think
of this book and that may be what makes
it different from any other book is that
I've not used any computer jargon in it
the word cyber appears only twice in the
book once on the cover because the
publisher insists on it and once in the
grocery where I say this is a word
that's mainly used to confuse rather
than illuminate when we talk about
public health we don't talk about
epidemiology you don't talk about
virology we don't talk about the details
of how the DNA work in bacteria we have
very simple messages now wash your hands
coughs and sneezes spread diseases we
have very simple messages which get
across very complicated ideas in public
health and change behavior when it's
Road Safety we have very simple messages
you don't need to know the difference
between a dungeon pin and a gasket to be
a safe driver of a safe car and we're
not there yet on the Internet but
fundamentally the solutions the problems
we have are not primarily technical we
kind of know what we need to do and I'm
get into that in the Q&A it's telling me
stuff like virtualization identity
assurance defense-in-depth better
network design the tools are being
secured against most threats are pretty
much there the problem is changing human
behavior
it's the attackers are humans we need to
deter them easy to get into the criminal
economy and disrupt it raise the cost of
doing business for them and we need to
say to people who don't at the moment
feel that they're hurting actually are
hurting and people who don't at the
moment feel they're scared actually
should be scared because when people are
scared and hurting then they changed
their behaviors whether it's individuals
companies governments or anything else
so going to stop there I look forward
particularly to robust questions so if
you've read the book and you think it's
rubbish please tell
if you haven't read the book but you
still think it's rubbish you can be
attacked for that if you want to ask a
question or two about Russia that's it
that's okay too but we're going to kick
off some questions in the podium said Lt
Tom yes if I could just sort of have you
pursue the issue you mentioned about
some of the simple measures that will
take place and although the bloomie
prognosis is this a we in a period now
we will talk about the Wild West Wild
West I mean Western the United States
the 19th century enough other wild
West's in other words where they're
sorting these things out and it will
take several years or as as these things
become uncovered that based on where we
were maybe five or ten years ago we're
moving in the right direction either by
governments or by personal or is that we
really marking time and still looking
for way ahead
I guess worse I think we're losing you
know our vulnerability is increasing all
the time the criminal economy is getting
more more sophisticated when I first
started writing about this book I was
impressed by the idea that you could
sell malware malevolent software on the
dark web and there was some kind of
after sales service they now sell it
with three tiers of customer support
there's a basic helpline which is kind
of how do I make this work second tier
helpline for can you help me tweak it so
it works in this particular way and the
third tier for under the hood deep in
the code I don't think this lines right
can you um can you help so I think that
are both the threats the surface the
number of things that are vulnerable to
attack is increasing particularly with
the Internet of Things which were
tumbling into you absolutely had long
and the criminal economy is getting far
more sophisticated and to use your Wild
West analogy we don't have the sheriff
we don't have the posse and we don't
really have the visualization we know
the I mean I are not sure you can still
say this because it sounds being
pejorative we know there are Indians out
there in the hills but we don't know who
they can attack how they're going to
attack what's going to happen I'm not
making it nasty point about Native
Americans is just as you know some
general cultural contra reference in
there and I think we've got to start um
at a very basic level of making people
feel this is not that momenta thing this
is different from any real world analogy
or not or not it's fairly different for
real world analogies a badly run
computer may be no threat to you but it
may be doing something ripped very bad
to somebody else said the bottom net
which is something that people find very
hard to visualize a million enslaved
computers whose owners have no idea that
that attachment they clicked on all that
link they open is just taking a little
bit of the processing part little bit of
the memory and has made that computer
into something that can then do a huge
DDoS attack and knock a website off air
can be used to in it to terms spread
more malware there's lots of things you
can do with the botnet and the person
who's got the infected computer system
this may be cost me if five cents a year
in electricity I mean doesn't impede the
function of my computer why should I
worry
well our answer to that should be it's
as if you have multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis or type of typhoid or
something like that you can be a carrier
of a disease that isn't hurting you but
it is hatty endangering everybody you
have contact with and even in here the
most freedom-loving states in america if
you have a communicable disease they
will lock you up in your house they will
consign you to hospital and they will
say you get treatment you don't go out
of this place until you're cured so we
have ways to think about this in the
road we haven't yet adapted that to
computers his is there any country
that's more head than say the United
States for instance when Estonia had
that massive hack several years ago have
they taken any measures that appear to
be forwarding this kind of measures yet
but and other least aliens in the
audience because you have permission to
blush noise I'm going to praise your
country
I'm a huge fan of the Estonians and
there's three things I think are really
important here
one is that ddos attack it's a very
crude kind of cyberattack this is kind
of high-end stuff with you know you see
in the Hollywood screenplay this is
basically a straightforward swamping
attack it didn't knock them over it
impeded things it's slowed things down a
few websites went down but they did not
succeed in bring the Estonian economy to
a halt it didn't destroy their banking
system it didn't do the sort of things
that the people who launched it may have
thought they were they thought he was
going to do since then Estonia has got a
whole load better in terms of defending
itself against DDoS and also looking at
the critical national infrastructure and
obviously that's easy in a country of a
million people this is like a sneer
small US state but there's plenty of
stuff there we can look at but I think
the most important thing about Estonia
predates this attack and that is that
they've got the fundamental business of
identity assurance absolutely late and
that is with this thing which is called
in they have this for foreigners and for
locals but the difference is that for a
foreigner you don't get a photo on it
this is an Estonian national ID card and
your identity is in this chip and you
don't share that your immutable personal
data with all the people you need to
identify yourself to you type in a pin
code the pin code kicks with the chip
and it sends a signal saying yes this is
fine this is indeed edward lucas if you
want to give a digital signature say i
need to sign a document i put in a five
digit PIN code and that is a legally
binding signature now in most countries
if you ask for a digital signature of
the internet what people do is they
print out a document they sign it with a
wet signature then they make a PDF of it
and then they email it back to you and
this is somehow supposed to be secure I
simply cannot understand this in most
countries
identity and access a hopelessly
conflated so if you want to rent a
microphone system sort of thing I'm
talking on now and you want to rent that
in Britain you hand over your address
your date of birth and a copy of your
driving license or
possible that's enough information to
open a bank account just to rent a radio
microphone system this is absolute grace
we are handing those are immutable
personal date personal data you will
never get another date of birth you'll
never get another mother's maiden name
you'll never get another fingerprint
you'll never get another retina if you
hand that stuff over and it's complete
you're in serious trouble and we use
this immutable personal data all the
time in a way that is kind of reckless
open to to theft it's much better to
have it this cryptographically based
identity and I'm not saying the Estonian
system is going to be the one that wins
because the Singaporeans have looked at
Estonia they flew a big delegation into
Estonia and said this is great we want
to do this for all of East Asia it's a
funny thing about governments people are
often quite unwilling to trust their own
government maybe for good reasons but if
you say this is just a service provided
by another government you can use it or
not use it's a voluntary opt-in system
people are queuing up they have issued
10,000 of these since they launched
these Safari modes you can pick one of
the Estonian embassy just down the road
I think $40 or something smaller so I
think that this this solves one of our
fundamental problems on the Internet
which is proving who we are and proving
who are doing business with because
civilization if you think about it is
based on the trustful interaction
between people who don't know each other
very well and we use all five of our
senses we have all sorts of you know
learned responses and other cues and
safeguards and so on which means that we
can do business with each other face to
face and also by by letter and so on and
these things to developed but we don't
have a way of doing that over the
Internet I can't prove Who I am on the
Internet
you can't prove it it's really me the
two of us can't get together and prove
that someone else is who they say they
are and this is one of the biggest
vulnerabilities that we thought and
these sort of systems I think can solve
that so in a gay Estonia there's you
mentioned at least three different
aspects of this of the cyber phobia one
is criminals draining accounts of all
kinds the second of all will say perhaps
intelligence of getting OPM data for
their own for whoever's own purposes
probably not for financial gain unless
they sell it to someone and third a
France system uses an example stud snip
that was an offensive use of this of
those are we looking at different actors
for instance States in some cases versus
criminal individuals another in other
words are these very separate
enterprises that we can separate are
they should they be seen as one well I'm
here in Hall it's the easiest way to
look at this is to say that there are
some things that really only governments
can do high-end national intelligence
services have got amazing capabilities
for example in truven up bulk data you
can be a forward or against it but that
is something that only government can do
endpoint vulnerabilities getting stuff
into firmware into a keyboard that has a
key logger on it and get them finding
everything that's typed on the keyboard
and then getting that back to some
command and control server in a secure
way getting data off screens hacks of
mobile devices planting stuff on an on a
computer from a mobile device that isn't
physically connected to it these are
pretty sophisticated capabilities and
you can buy some bits of them on the
internet you can you can buy very simple
malware which you can send us a text
message and when the person opens it it
infects their fence you can buy that but
there's a quite a lot of stuff that only
governments can do expensive buying
expensive zero-day vulnerabilities holes
and software or hardware that nobody
else knows about these go for 50
thousand maybe even a hundred thousand
dollars likely the good ones are very
expensive and again it's a sort of
budgetary thing and you put those
capabilities together and you get
something like Stuxnet which only really
a government could have done we
speculate it's the American government
actually boasted about it so it's no
longer really secret but you know before
against that too but that that's kind of
you
Aarthi this is the least of our worries
for all the people because I guess
everybody has seen the Bourne Identity
and the Bourne trilogy and there's a
great films that they are not
documentaries yeah I'm not Jason Bourne
no one in this room is Jason Bourne we
are being attacked all the time in a
much simpler way which is much more like
to do bad things to our work for our
lives I think too leaving aside the
high-end stuff then so many of the
vulnerabilities are open to anybody if I
want to get onto the arm size Network
whether I want to get on cuz I want to
steal stuff I'm gonna find out how you
do your invoicing and send you some
focus invoices which you'll pay I want
to steal some data I want to maybe get
in and change my grade so I do a better
job with all sorts of reasons some ones
get onto the network initially they're
going the same way they were going to
LinkedIn find someone who's got lots of
she works at sise find out who they
worked in the past set up a gmail
address from old colleague at gmail.com
and send a message saying hi Bob I find
these pics would you like to have a look
take a look and then the person will
probably pick on them nothing opens they
think it's a mistake they forget all
about it and this very basic spear
phishing attacks links links and
attachments can be used for by any one
of those threat actives and I think the
OPM hack actually started with someone
with with us with a targeted spear
phishing attack which then got them onto
the network and then of course once
you're on the network then there's you
may need sophisticated tools to try and
get control loot over the network you
may be able to go quite is quite
unsophisticated to us depends what
you're exactly but this is it is this
very big lump of simple vulnerability
which everybody could exploit okay let's
go to the audience if we're good and we
have a microphone if you just wait just
raise your hand and until the microphone
gets to you Emily will write yes grant
if you just introduce yourself before
you may ask the question
much mr. Lucas for doing this my name is
Marcus bender I work for German National
Public Radio here in Washington what I'm
concerned about even more than the
technical aspect of all of those things
is the fact that the the American
government employed someone who didn't
even have an a college degree it got him
into you know the most sensitive
government systems and he could manage
to get all those things out and get away
with it
until now at least so how do you think
governments or societies can protect
themselves from those kinds of breaches
isn't that the I mean the regular thing
that people actually steal something you
know well it's a great question what's
so worrying is you didn't actually
mention the name of snow so it could it
be it could have been some other hands
well you know the and I think it there's
been there's government likes to beat up
industry over security and their right
to do it I think it's scandalous that we
don't share information better between
different companies in the same industry
across industries we need to a much
better job about protecting the data
that is entrusted to us as companies
whether it's the data of our employees
of our suppliers of our customers or
anybody else and I think there should be
in serious penalties for people who are
careless and reckless that should be
civil and criminal liability and that's
all fine but if you want to see a really
badly designed Network you're more
likely to find it actually in the public
sector than in the in the private sector
it's absolutely terrifying how badly
protected at the out-of-date systems
badly administered by demoralized
careless people and this stops happening
again and again and again and and one I
think you know one could make several
points one is that I think this is a
very good reason why
should not support any government
mandated attempts to weaken encryption
if there's going to be government
mandated backdoors in commercially
provided encryption that will be a
fantastic target for criminals and I
have zero confidence that those it's as
if everybody in the country has to give
a a front door key to the government to
make sure that there's no front door key
their front door that the government
can't open and that you know his front
door keys neatly labeled kept down in
your local police station you don't have
to be a you know Agatha Christie to
think that could be an interesting for
criminals so I think we should be have
very modest expectations of comments
abilities to keep our data secret and we
should be much tougher on what we share
the government's and again coming back
to Estonia
one of the beauties of the Estonian
system is not only is everything
encrypted but there's no single database
there's no single point of vulnerability
they have a federation of databases
which are connected by something called
the X road which works on a very simple
but robust sub challenge response system
so it would be really hard and not
saying it's impossible cuz nothing is
impossible but something like the OPM
hat would be really really difficult to
do it Estonia need the cooperation of
lots and lots of people and you'd have
to do very quickly than nobody
and simultaneously at different points
before for it for noses and I suppose
the final point I'd make is that why do
we keep all this stuff in electronic
databases anyway if you look at the John
the films that are we made of the John
John le carré novels there's one which
has just slipped my mind where they have
to go into the mi6 registry and steal a
file now these days you would probably
hack in there you had physically get
into the registry you had to distract
the person who was there to stop you
copying files you had to get access
physically to a file it was logged in
and logged out who looked at it for how
long if you wanted to steal all the
documents in that registry you'd have
had to attack the building with a major
military for
then take the stuff away in trucks and
the OPM was like that only 20-30 years
ago the Chinese would have needed trucks
to take the stuff out of the APM and now
you can do it on a USB stick so I think
one of the big lessons
think really hard and ask your
government why are you keeping the stuff
online
you've got convenience absolutely but is
that really worth the vulnerability and
one of the best stories that I was I've
come across this year The Economist is
the boom in manual typewriters
intelligence agencies of buying manual
typewriters and calm people because you
know you can very hot you can't there's
a saying I heard from some cybersecurity
guy you can't hack a steam engine has no
electronics and often electrical has
nothing to fact steam agent is actually
for anyone here's interesting Carrington
events steam engines would actually
survive a Carrington event in a way that
no other form of transport would so you
know we have to be quite prudent about
moving away from things that can't be
hacked and a very resilient towards
things that are seem convenient that are
actually potentially vulnerable
Thank You mr. Lucas um my name is hey
want they study energy and environment
here but before sites I used to work for
the Korean government agency doing um
cybersecurity internet policy on I think
the reason international political
environment has kind of come to the
stage that international norms building
is very important in the cyber space but
here are you from your example in
Estonia and other East Asian like cases
I feel like it's not only the states
that have different on perceptions on
cyber space but also it's the people of
each state have different values and
different cultural norms that they
expect from the cyber space so I kind of
want to hear on what you think about is
it even like necessary to build
international like norms is it even
plausible or is it more practical and
make it doesn't make more sense when you
come when we have more efforts that are
done
domestically um within Canada national
boundary well it's a great question and
I think we are developing we're
beginning to develop norms in the way we
use social media yeah I mean I was
looking some emails that I had done been
sending and receiving about 10 15 years
ago and I noticed a lot of people use
capital letters to show they were angry
and that's become socially unacceptable
now we actually have normas are you
don't you that this sort of way we
interact by email we've just and people
sent very long emails in the old days
and now people tend to send very short
heroes it's kind of wound to send very
long emails continue to expect people to
read it so I think enormous in any kind
of human interaction start developing
and that's good I think that there's a
if you look at shipping which is was the
first really sort of global industry we
develop we slowly developed in the
maritime world oh yeah we had enormous
about emergencies yeah it was the duty
of every seafarers to stop and pick up
other seafarers in distress you do it
for them because they do it for you it's
not really enforced but it happens
pretty well we have we developed ways of
messaging you know the days before an
electronic messaging we have played
flags which people put up saying and I'm
in quarantine don't come near my boat
again that sort of work we dealt with
parents we had the lessons of parents
and the Barbary pirates and that sort of
was something American for America's I
think first overseas military engagement
was on going after pirates they were
endangering American shipping so this
stuff does it builds up on a kind of
case-by-case basis I think the
fundamental problem is that the Internet
is a means for doing other things and
the norms about those other things vary
very widely say you could quite easily I
think get the banks of the world getting
together saying we're going to have very
tough rules about preventing people
cashing out the proceeds of cybercrime
the Kazon cybercrime now is you get into
someone's elect internet banking you get
them to do something stupid and then you
steal their money now that money doesn't
appear in your pocket magically you
transfer it to another bank and then to
another bank and into another bank and
at each point you're doing the transfer
there is a point of vulnerability
because someone had to open that account
now maybe you've hijacked another
account it's gain from one hijacked
account another hi Jenica but at some
point a physical person went into a bank
and opened the account there was some so
we could have a I could quite easily
imagine a lot of reputable banks any
together saying we're going to set up
norms for transfers that makes it much
easier to trace stolen money as it hops
from country to country from account to
account and if you don't play by our
rules we may stop transferring money to
you and you to have reputable banks in
Russia and China and everywhere else in
the world saying yeah we want to play we
want to be in on that so I can see that
happening what's much harder is on
things
the use of information because if you
look at the there's been a big push from
Russia and China to bring the internet
under the control of the UN agency the
International Telecommunications Union
which is the body that censor dialing
codes and before that the rules for
Telegraph's and telegrams and that kind
of makes sense you know why not have a
UN agency in charge it might well work
better than the ICANN and these things
we have at the moment but the problem is
that one of the things that Russia and
China want to deal with is what they
call information weapons that's what we
call news then it's going to be we are
not going to reach consensus on that
because they think it's part of national
sovereignty on the Internet is the dump
should be able to control what
information goes in and out and we say
no that is absolutely totally
unacceptable I'm never going to have
anything to do with that but by the way
can you accomplish with child
pornography because that's information
which we regard child abuse images which
we've got is totally unacceptable and it
may be hosted on your servers in these
countries so I'm not going for moral
equivalence here but countries having
radically different ideas of what is
accessible what one country says is
terrorism is another country freedom
fighter so you can have a global ban on
terrorism we're not going to have
terrorism on the Internet and the
Chinese government then comes to have a
host of the Tibetan government-in-exile
and says you've got extremists on your
server
take it down what's going to happen so I
think we have to be very modest in our
expectations where there is a clear
common interest as there has been in
shipping we'll make some progress where
there's no common interest I think we
just have to accept it's not going to
happen
yes
am i affirm sighs second-year student
studying international finance I just
want to follow up on the previous
question regarding domestic legislations
in preventing cyber cyber security and
I'm not sure whether you're familiar
with the information sharing act that
are currently more absolutely yeah yeah
Congress so there's this a matter like
proposed like advocated by most
financial institutions and also many
other business in the American and I'm
just want to assure your comments on how
likely it's going to be passed and why
the technology companies are at a
different stand that they kind of
opposed the the cybersecurity
information sharing act 2015 yeah she's
just so confusing for me yeah it's this
this falls into us at the economists we
call the classic way of really boring
and really exciting most people have no
idea about this once you get into this
this becomes very important it's been
sigh think five years it's been sitting
there bouncing around in the Senate and
the house and different versions of the
bill and amendments and so on and it's
now got some momentum and it's it's in
this precedence which I know works
brilliantly well in this time where
people put aside their party differences
and concentrate on something that's
actually going to work say the house and
the the Senate said sorting out some
details
it does have bipartisan support that's
quite impressive a lot of the tech I
mean I was talking to IBM the other day
they really support this they there's a
lot of that obviously not everybody's
happy with it but there seems to be
pretty broad consensus across industry
that people want
for example people worried about the
antitrust side you get every major
company in industry in the same world
and the first thing they say is should
we all be here is that everything we
allowed to talk about because you know
we don't want to go to jail and and if
you're talking about stuff that could be
seen as from an antitrust point of view
as problematic in cooperation you want
to have bulletproof
legal protection on that now I think
those fears are probably overstated and
you know companies love saying we can't
do this for antitrust reasons but in
seize that gives something
I think we've already got quite a lot of
information-sharing but I I want to see
a mandatory breach reporting I think if
this if sighs have Legionnaires disease
and it's air conditioning the management
of sites would not say one arkham santa
thing about this because it would cause
our students to panic or some might see
us they would say oh my goodness who do
we have to tell what do we do so that we
don't get into trouble because
Legionnaires disease is a public health
menace we we need to take the same
attitude to Maui so we need really good
ways of identifying now well which we
don't really have a min because
sometimes the taxonomy is actually the
code sometimes it's who that where it's
coming from
sometimes it's how it's targeted
sometimes it's what the you know what it
actually did and so I think trying to
there's a there's a kind of collective
action problem there it's worth trying
to to make everybody report malware the
same way I think we'll see from a kind
of the other collective action problem
is that it's always going to be in the
interest of individual companies to say
to keep quiet about an attack because
they don't want their shareholders to
see them they don't their share price to
go down they didn't want you know all
the things but if everybody's doing it
then you can also to be brave together
so I think pushing them again I'm not
Shawn legislation is absolutely
necessary I think maybe you could have
done it more on voluntary basis so I'm
I'm kind of agnostic but I'm I'm glad to
see there's at least some legislative
attention on this because that this
comes after five years of basically
nothing
hi my name is Jen Whedon I've been in
the security industry for quite a while
and my question was around your thoughts
on the role of the private sector
particularly security companies with
threat Intel teams that expose cyber
operations and point fingers you know do
do attribution in my experience there's
a divide within the community on the
appropriateness of that and the
effectiveness of that because often with
these campaigns you can out them you can
share indicators you can point fin your
fingers but it really only causes a
tactical disruption rather than some
sort of strategic change in my opinion
so it'd be curious about your thoughts
on sort of the ethics of private
companies doing attribution and exposing
these indicators and if you think in the
long term this will do anything or if
they're just sort of glorified marketing
fodder well it may be big I mean it's
clearly in the interest of cyber
security companies to show they can do
stuff and for many of them that would
actually be quite a challenge see yeah
there's a an amazing amount of cyber
security product and service which is
basically useless and is bought by
people who don't really understand the
problem they need to do something and
they say this has got in a bit famous
company's name on it and I'm not going
to get far because I bought this company
says will it actually defend it and very
likely not we are so I'm yeah I'm not a
big sort of booster for the
cybersecurity industry and you they are
like any company they will sort of talk
up talk up what they do but I think the
real question is how do we raise the
cost of doing business in the criminal
economy
and I think certainly meaning people has
a role there because if you're in
somewhere on the other side of the world
and you go by an alias you're in chat
rooms you buy and sell malware maybe
develop it you're making quite a little
money it comes in Bitcoin you cast a
Bitcoin out and you're and then suddenly
you are named and you realize I can
never go to a civilized country I can
never go into the European Union I can
never go to any g20 country maybe I make
you know you were kind of suddenly
thinking this was maybe not such a smart
idea and we can start building our
profiles of people and scaring them from
that point of view I think the kim.com
I'm not making any comment about the Kim
calm case particularly but I think
people like Kim calm thought they were
invulnerable and then one day turned out
they weren't available and they were
taken away to jail facing facing
criminal charges so I think companies
have a role in in in reducing the
comfort zone I think the more tricky
question is when it comes to hacking to
it to honey pots honey nets and hacking
back and I guess everybody here smilling
with this but this is where you put
stuff on your network which isn't the
real secret it's just labelled tempting
secret and then the bad guys going and
they steal it and they take it back onto
their network but there's some malware
that you put in this file which then
affects their network and it may be a
beacon sensor you know where it's gone
it maybe opens up their network to your
scrutiny the Georgian government did
this very brilliantly when they they
realized they were being hacked by the
Russian note 4 intelligence GRU so they
put a fire on their network which was
called something like secret NATO war
plans to attack Russia and of course the
Russians spotted it stole it opened it
it was laden with malware which had been
supplied to Georgia by an ally who's
never been named so obviously I could
possibly imagine who that might be
and the Russians open didn't he turned
on though and first way hoovered up
everything on their network and sent it
back to the the Georgians and presumably
from there to the anonymous Ally it also
turned on the webcam and the Georgians
did a wonderful
for words they put on the internet where
you saw these GRU guys sitting there in
their t-shirts laughing about hey we've
got this great stuff in the georgians
with a microphone and webcam on that
computer to turn on so no that is not
legal you can do that as a government
you do as intelligent agents
intelligence agencies are wired to break
the look that's what they're there for
but as a private person you can't do
that in Britain we have the computer
misuse Act and if only thing you're
happening to my computer I put something
there you seal it goes back onto your
computer I've just manipulated your
computer without your consent and I can
be prosecuted so we need to think really
carefully about what the legal framework
is for kind of self cyber self defense
in the kinetic world we understand this
very well you have a very controversial
in this country have you're Stand Your
Ground laws but in most countries
there's pretty good defensive he hit me
so I hit him back and I broke his jaw I
killed him but you know he did hit me
first and I can prove that and so we
haven't yet worked out the cyber version
of that and particularly what we can you
outsource that capability to a security
company you know if so if you come and
hit me can I pay him to hit you because
you hit me and in the kinetic world
that's not allowed I have to do the
hitting myself I can't get my bodyguards
to come beat you up but in so are we
gonna say that in the cyber world that's
okay I think it probably is but with me
at work very early stage at the moment
of thinking thinking this one through
can we have some questions from this
side entirely focused yeah go ahead
well they're getting there just that one
question just to continue to pull that
thread has it been
you've been party to discussions about
what these what kind of attacks could be
actually considered acts of war or is
that and that is a really tricky
question and you've got two axes to the
problem one is the attribution somebody
don't join the Cuban Missile Crisis
JFK knew that those were Soviet ships
the Soviets knew that this was they were
American missiles in Turkey we had no
doubt that was not our problem working
on who did it and in the digital world
you can be really flopped about who
didn't attacks that's one number one
secondly it can be really hard to work
out what actually was this attack
if you run to take a hypothetical
example you run Russia's missile defense
computer network this is the sensors and
all the equipment that tells Russia are
we being attacked by another country and
you are you suddenly notice that someone
has breached your network
something's wrong someone was in there
now was that espionage they were trying
to find out how it worked was it with
Conesus they're trying to find out how
to break it are they actually trying to
break it right now now the prudent
response for you is probably to turn the
computer off and go back to a manual
system maybe you put your forces on
alert now imagine that you are not the
person running the Russian system but
you are another country America and you
have no idea maybe it was your spies
maybe it was another espionage service
has been on the Russian computer so as
far as you're concerned it's all norm
and suddenly they turn off their
computer goes mad and put their force
over hey why are they doing that
well I better do something so you put
your you raise your low level now go
back imagining of the Russians first of
all you think the Americans attacked
your computer network and now they've
put there for similar what you better do
something so we're in a very dangerous
position here when we don't know what
the attack is and we don't know who's
doing it and so I think we have to have
a great deal more emphasis on these kind
of mill mill hot line sort of things
this is a far more difficult problem
than we had done with with nuclear
joining the Cold War and essentially
that there may be no answers to solve it
because you can never you can't do
deterrence with digital weapons because
you can't say what you've got if you
said what you've got the other side
would then work out how to stop it you
also don't know whether your digital
deterrent is actually going to work a
tox it may be based on some
versus the other side as perhaps and you
don't know so there's a double yeah
you've got both eyes shot at some extent
all on that which makes it even more
difficult so a question of that hi my
name is Katherine siren and I'm a second
year student here especially in conflict
management and this is fairly new
territory for me so I'll definitely be
picking up a copy of that book and I
hope this isn't too ignorant to question
but I'm very interested in the role of
the law in this and my sense from what
you said earlier is that it currently
lacks the teeth to deter potential
criminals do you think that the problem
at the moment is that there are laws but
they're not being applied as they should
or do you think that the law the legal
systems have to play catch-up
in which case you know can hackers be
seen as opportunists rather than
criminals in the situation in which the
law currently isn't clearly forbidding
what they're doing and also if you do
think the legal systems need to play
catch-up where where are you you know
who here is their onus on you know do
you want to see the international
community doing more to sort of deal
with the threats which is clearly
transnational yeah well he the last
point you made is probably most
important that we are dealing with a
list of the malefactors were dealing
with are working across national borders
not always but mostly and our criminal
justice systems are basic the very
national sometimes they're even
submerged as we've seen it in in Belgium
since they're with the terror attacks so
yes that that's a problem cross that
there are mechanisms for cooperation but
they take days weeks and months and if
you're dealing with a live case of
cybercrime you have minutes the money's
just left an account can we catch it
before it disappears off into Bitcoin
land and so absolutely we've got it just
of the basic level of bureaucratic
cooperation there's huge amounts of
low-hanging fruit which we just have to
get our police forces out of their
comfort zone and lots of them are not
digital natives they don't really
they don't like working with foreigners
they didn't necessarily trust foreigners
but that's that's all got to change and
maybe some legal changes then there's
the question of whether law is too tough
and I think it's we've gone the wrong
way about dealing with hackers that our
approach is hackers or criminals you
know some comes and sprays graffiti on
the windows here
well that's criminal damage then go to
jail we should be thinking much more
about the kind of the individual hackers
as a social problem rather as a criminal
justice problem it doesn't make sense to
take these people and lock them up
without computers for ten years some
extreme cases maybe that's necessary and
we need to a much better job at finding
people who are often not in formal
education maybe come from quite sort of
troubled backgrounds have really find
their self-realization through the
keyboard and a drifting in to this dark
world with a mixture of bravado I want
to make a bit of money maybe a bit of
personal score settling maybe some
rather than of ill-thought-out political
ideas but we need to be moving these
people up and saying you could be adding
having a nice job and only lots of money
and be a respected member of community
if you just turn your skills from going
that way to that way
and so I think criminalizing hackers
isn't really is it is a mistake and all
the problems with the law enforcement is
they say our dramas to catch criminals
these are criminals and we've caught
them so therefore we have to do
something it'll be a deterrent it's not
a deterrent doesn't work there I think
was the other parts of criminal law
we've got to get our making clear oh
what the in what really constitutes a
breach what's the and we've seen this
revenge porn which is a kind of cyber
attack this is a something that didn't
really exist before the internet now
revenge porn is a serious problem and
we've got a saint yeah and I think we
need to have that as a new crime was
coming in in Britain there that the a
couple of this the sharing of an image
without the consent of the person
concerned with malicious
that is not a crime so that sort of we
criminalize French people that's great
I'm in favor of that and then finally
understood perhaps in a way it's the
most important thing I think we need to
think about the civil side because miss
people are more worried about being sued
than they are worried about against jail
because most people are not natural
criminals and they think you know I'm
not I'm not but I might do something
just by being careless that means I get
sued so therefore I better be careful
and so there I think we need to look a
lot and again in this country death
protection these class-action lawsuits
that have just started from the Army
with the target attack I think a
harbinger of things that are going to
come people are going to say I gave you
my immutable personal data you lost it
I'm going to see you
and we're going to get a whole range of
case law being precedent which is gonna
scare people they're gonna think wow
company eggs bad stuff happened I don't
want to do that what do I have to do
differently and very funny we also need
to have some legal standards and if you
have if you're an electrician you don't
say I have this neat idea for saving
money on cabling which is I won't use
insulation on the bits that don't need
it you can't do that there's a legal
standard if you operate a railway a
railroad there are illegal standards and
I think we need to have some basic
standards over the country if you run a
company you have to file accounts public
company has to be a lot of accounts and
so the sort of cyber aspect of running a
company I think you should say you have
to have a qualified information and I
didn't mean Shirin person out of senior
level them the company working out of
the General Counsel's office is not a
cost Center it's a compliance issue you
have to have regular testing you have to
encrypt data and other people's personal
data if you have it on the network and I
think covered by law you have to have
two-factor authentication
none of that is a magic bullet it won't
stop things but it would stop an awful
lot of the very stupid things we have at
the moment such as the OPM oh yeah if
they've had two factor authentication
would have happened
now can I ask a pair of questions about
information on news and get your
impression of it first of all how
successful do you think countries such
as Russia or China can be in restricting
news that is so much available through
the internet and the second part of that
is is on the subject of WikiLeaks in
other words a system that is looking for
the complete openness of news
or complete information taking that
exposing the acts of governments
anywhere how do you come down on those
two issues and one how available was it
and two in terms of WikiLeaks is this
something we're going to have to
business it now a new fact of life on
the news I'm quite depressed I think ten
years ago people thought we're in the
golden age of information that
governments would never be able to close
down information sources that you could
everybody was going to be a citizen
journalist we'd have amazing amounts of
information amazing ways of processing
it and if the Chinese and the Russians
and the others would just have to get
used to living a free open world of
information well that really hasn't
happened we have seen the ability of the
Russians to dominate their information
space with propaganda the Chinese using
a mixture of propaganda but just
technical means to keep out Twitter and
other things and it kind of works you
know you did PPO there'll be a small
percentage of super curious people
who'll set up VPNs and try and get
around these firewalls but a lot of
people it's a it's a hassle and so long
as what's available is reasonably
interesting they're not burning to find
out what's happening on the other side
so I'm quite depressed about that
think also news organizations with the
exception of the economics - basically
very short of money so we're seeing a
the business model that sustains news
has been collapsing German public radio
remains absolutely excellent both and on
the second question which I've just been
Thierry forgotten now WikiLeaks weakness
I think that democratic governments have
the right to have secrets if the
government can't keep a secret it's not
really a government because some of
those secrets are things that have been
entrusted to it so just as a little
matter of first principles I believe
that government and and if it's a
democratic if it's a totalitarian
government
I support stealing those secrets if it's
democratic government I support support
defending and I think even
dumas ang England Greenwald doesn't say
we should have secrets he thinks they're
the wrong secret so then you get your
question about what should be kept
secret I think there's the question of
oversight and you have in this country
the kind of trifecta of
lawmakers judicial oversight and
unelected executive that's a lot better
than other countries have I know a lot
of people think it's not nearly enough
but you know once you get into the
debate about oversight a lot of people
rapidly lose interest because discussing
you try to say the most important
question in America today is whether the
judges on the FISA Court should be
appointed just by the Chief Justice or
by all the members the Supreme Court is
a woman you can you can kill a party
stone-dead by trying to get the
conversational to that whereas talking
about the Bourne Identity is come really
in shafting the young the other thing
that struck me on WikiLeaks and we have
a senior State Department official in
the room but I would say this anyway it
told me two things one is wow these guys
can write and there's one guy who wrote
a telegram that was so good we actually
wrote to them and said you can have a
job if you ever want to leave the State
Park you can work for the Economist we
don't printed that at length it was just
a brilliant piece of writing it was a
description of a Chechen wedding
an American taxpayer I wish I'm not I
was I felt there's a lot of buried
talent there in the State Department
which I couldn't quite see why that had
to be classified I mean maybe people
would say our diplomats weren't get
invited to Chechen weddings if they
write about it and it sort of goes up
but I think with a little bit of
tweaking you could get round there so I
thought there's a massive problem this
country of over-classification
if 30 months stuff is classified mr.
WikiLeaks is so boring that nobody wants
to read it you know the you just as it's
classified secret or restricted doesn't
actually mean it's interesting but what
bothered me and this is the really
serious point is that people had helped
the American government because they
believe in what America stands for and
they put they'd done it on the basis
that their identity would not be made
and now it's known and they were in past
the world where the retribution is quite
severe and there's been a lot of your
tax money has now gone on resetting
people who are in danger you can't live
in their countries anymore they can't go
back and see their families anymore
they're they can't do their jobs anymore
this is massive disruption and nobody
really thought about that
the WikiLeaks people were so excited
about the fact it was all secret they
didn't really think about what was the
kind of trust bargain that lay behind us
and we interviewed us an economist about
this and I apologize for profanity but I
certainly we pressed him very hard on
what happens to the Afghans who were
helping the Americans against the
Taliban presumably debts for the Taliban
they were helping Americans why is it
right to give their and he said they're
collaborators far I apologized the guy
like that's what he said I think that's
reckless I think that's inhuman I can't
understand how you can make a moral
justification for doing that okay now
time is up I want to thank the audience
for your questions thank you mr. Lucas
for really talking the very straight
terms not cyber terms in terms of what
the Sunday job we didn't teach I thank
you very much
[Applause]